hey 42 here we all know the story boy
meets girl boy loses girl boy finds girl
in a bar in nepal and saves her from the
nazis in return for which she gives him
a mystical medallion
then they head off to discover a chest
containing the ten commandments in order
to prevent it from being used by the
forces of evil to help them take over
the world
it's a tale as old as time right
the film fans amongst you plus any
budding archaeologists may have realized
that what i just loosely described was
the plot of the film raiders of the lost
dock in which case you might be forgiven
for thinking that it's not a tale as old
as time because it came out in 1981
which in reality makes it a tale as old
as
nine to five by dolly parton love that
song
but in some ways it really is a tale as
old as time because the artifact indiana
jones and his old flame marion were
searching for is said to have been made
some 3 000 years ago
since then it's been depicted not just
on the silver screen but in numerous
works of art countless books several
epic poems
oh and the bible
it's really big in the bible
i'm talking of course about the ark of
the covenant it's indisputedly one of
the most famous objects in history
and yet nobody has set eyes on it in two
and a half thousand years so
what happened to it
and perhaps more importantly did it
actually exist in the first place
if you love travelling like i do then
you'll love the fastest and easiest vpn
surf shock did you know surf shock helps
you to avoid price discrimination based
on your location so you can save money
on plane tickets and car rentals whilst
travelling surf shark runs on any device
anywhere and it's packed full of
features such as industry-leading
uncrackable encryption ip and dns leak
protection an internet kill switch of
your vpn drops out and 24 7 customer
support personally i use surfshark to
watch netflix content from other
countries such as the us that's usually
blocked here in the uk it's really easy
all you have to do is switch over your
location settings and there you have it
access to your favorite programs
surfshark maintains a strict no logs
policy and their network of 3200 servers
and over 95 countries runs 100 on ram so
they couldn't log your data even if they
wanted to by using the code 42 you'll
benefit from an 83 discount plus three
extra mums for free all you have to do
is click the special link in the
description below don't miss out and
thanks to surf shark for sponsoring this
video
according to exodus that's the book of
the bible not the bob marley album
god told moses to see to it that the ark
was built by the israelites the people
moses had previously led out of slavery
in egypt
moses julie did this and an ornate chest
was constructed from wood
gilded with gold and covered by a gold
lid replete with two gold ornamental
cherubs
basically if you like gold this was the
ark for you
the bible tells us that inside the ark
moses placed a stone tablets on which
the ten commandments were written as
well as two other holy relics
perhaps unsurprisingly given its divine
contents the ark is described as having
incredible power
admittedly there doesn't seem to be any
historical references to it melting
people's faces off as is the case in the
indiana jones film but it's said to have
been the source for several other
miracles the most spectacular of which
took place during the battle of jericho
when the israelites laid siege to
jericho they proceeded to march the ark
around the city walls every day for six
days i can only imagine that the king of
jericho spent most of that time
wondering if the israelites had lost
their marbles
that is until the seventh day when they
marched the ark around jericho one last
time
and the city's towering walls crumbled
into dust
as impressive as this arc-based warfare
may be it seems that having your own
magic arc didn't always guarantee
victory as several years later the
israelites battled the philistines and
lost
not only that but the ark itself was
captured not that it remained an arctic
triumph for the philistines for very
long
in fact it brought nothing but bad luck
to its new keepers as they were
afflicted by amongst other things a
nasty bounce of bubonic plague
apparently deciding this was a sign
because everything's a sign the
philistines swiftly returned the ark to
the israelites and it remained with them
for several generations residing in the
temple in jerusalem built by the wise
king solomon
it must be great to be referred to as
wise by everyone wasn't it
anyway
around 587 bc the babylonians attacked
jerusalem led by king nebuchadnezzar the
second they destroyed much of the city
including solomon's temple
so
what happened to the ark
well this is where the adventure really
begins
because from here on in there are
several theories as to where it went
if you believe indiana jones and frankly
why wouldn't you the man's a doctor for
goodness sake
then the ark was taken by the egyptian
pharaoh shishak long before the
babylonians attacked and was buried in a
really creepy vault in the ancient city
of tanis
you might remember the scene in raiders
when indy and marion are trapped down
there
it's dark their torches are slowly going
out and dozens of snakes are coming in
through the holes in the walls swiftly
followed by a load of mummified corpses
basically if you're playing indiana
jones bingo when you see that bit give
yourself a full house immediately
another story albeit one that sadly
involves fewer snakes and nazis
also begins with the ark being removed
from jerusalem before the babylonians
turn up in this version it was nabbed by
king menelik who took it back to his
home country of ethiopia
the ark of zion as followers of the
ethiopian orthodox church refer to it
is supposed to have been kept for a time
in a church on the island of tanakurkos
home to an order of monks historically
the monks took a vow of celibacy and no
women were allowed onto the part of the
island where they lived so i imagine
having a fancy art to look after was
quite a welcome distraction according to
ethiopian orthodoxy the ark was then
moved to the city of aksum
where it remains to this day in the
church of saint mary of zion
unfortunately for the rest of us and for
the sake of the ethiopian orthodox
church proving their claim
no one's actually allowed to see the ark
which is really convenient
except of course the monk who sits with
it day and night praying constantly
burning incense and paying tribute to
god
this guardian of the ark is referred to
as
the guardian of the ark which seems
pretty sensible when you think about it
but possibly my favorite theory is to
the ark's whereabouts claims that it
never left jerusalem in the first place
but was instead hidden from the
babylonians beneath temple mount the
site on which solomon's temple stood
before it was destroyed
fast forward 1500 years or so to the
early part of the 20th century and it
was the golden age of british
adventurers men with stiff upper lips
and implausibly posh-sounding names were
busy making their way across the globe
in service of the british empire
spreading religion sharing innovation
and stealing from the natives
you know good empire building stuff
one of these men with the stiffest of
upper lips and the most implausibly
possessed of names was montague brownlow
parker fifth earl of morley
parker's early life had followed a route
typical of many aristocratic young men
in the late 1800s he was educated at
eaton and then joined the british army
as an officer
monty which i'm pretty sure is what all
his poshmates would have called him
fought in the second boer war in south
africa and stayed there afterwards as to
personal assistance to a british general
adventures in far-off lands were
veritable catnip to old mbp so it's no
surprise that when he came across a
mysterious finnish scholar by the name
of dr volta juvelius he was deeply
intrigued by what the man had to say
and in fairness it was quite the story
in many ways worthy of indiana jones
himself juvelius claimed he was a code
breaker and that he'd found secret
ciphers in the book of ezekiel that
described exactly where the ark of the
covenant was buried
rather than treating this information
with the kind of suspicion most of us
would have demonstrated if a shadowy
mystic told us they'd discovered a
secret map to a lost treasure hidden in
plain sight inside the most widely read
book in history
monty's first reaction appears to have
been
great when do we start
between them monty and dr juvelius
recruited a group of adventurous
archaeologists secured the equivalent of
almost one million pounds in today's
money from some frankly irresponsible
investors and set off for palestine to
seek fortune and glory kid
fortune and glory
as it happens monty wasn't the first
brit to go digging around in the holy
city that dubious honor belonged to
general sir charles warren another
mustachioed adventurer type who'd
conducted an exploratory dig 50 years
earlier
and discovered a promising network of
tunnels underneath temple mount
he'd also uncovered an archaeologically
significant water channel that was named
warren's shaft in his honor
yeah
that hasn't aided too well has it
building on the work of sir charles
before him monty's excavation started in
the summer of 1909 and carried on
through 1910 and well into 1911.
but
two and a half years later
he still hadn't found the ark
desperate for results monty and co
decided the time had come to dig in the
dome of the rock
as you may know jerusalem is a city not
just revered by jews and christians it
also has massive significance for
muslims
the dome of the rock is the world's
oldest surviving example of islamic
architecture and a shrine that's deeply
revered
so when monty and the boys bribed the
guardian of the temple and started
[ __ ] up its floor
things were always going to go badly
which they julie did
when word got out about where these
plucky imperialists had decided to start
planting their shovels a full-scale riot
broke out and the group only just
managed to get out of jerusalem alive
making their escape on a yacht the
treasure hunters vowed to return though
believing they'd come very close to
discovering the ark
but before they had the chance to do so
the first world war broke out
the world was a very different place
after 1918 and ultimately our edwardian
expendables
never went back to finish what they'd
started
so were they indeed on the brink of
discovering an artifact which has
captivated people for thousands of years
is the ark of the covenant buried there
to this day
tantalizingly out of reach in the
tunnels beneath jerusalem well after
extensive research i can exclusively
reveal that the answer is
i have no idea
no one does
the ark may indeed be lying undisturbed
beneath that holiest of cities waiting
for a modern day monty to unearth it
it may be in ethiopia under the watchful
gaze of its presumably slightly bored
guardian it could be pretty much
anywhere
as recently as 2008 british university
professor tuda parfit whose name makes
him sound like a colour you'd use to
paint the spare room
claims to have tracked it down to hurrah
in zimbabwe but others believe it was
taken to france by the knights templar
and still others placed the ark in a
secret location inside a church in rome
but the truth is
we'll likely never know not just where
the ark is but if it ever actually
existed in the first place
after all underneath the fancy gold
grills
the bible tells us that the ark of the
covenant
was made of wood
which would likely have turned to dust
by now
as of today there simply isn't enough
evidence to draw any firm conclusions
but perhaps that's all for the best the
mystique the centuries-old tale of
celestial power
and of course the prospect that it might
yet one day be found
these are the reasons that from the
ancient world to the silver screen we've
remained so utterly transfixed by the
ark of the covenant
[Music]
thanks for watching